hey everyone it's Mike from waterfalls
and in this video I want to talk about
is one of the different types of order
flow footprint charts that you can look
at as a Trader and you know most of us
we use the regular bid ask footprint
which means you know you're comparing
the volume traded on the bid and the
offer like the bid ask footprint shows
you the volume traded on the bid as well
as the volume traded on the offer then
you can look at it in the two-way
auction so for example uh 105 40 you
know 24 contracts traded on the bid 11
contracts traded on the offer then you
would compare it what was traded on the
offer versus what was traded on the bid
at 105.39 and a half you can see 19
versus 11. 24 against 28 31 against 22
because you'd be looking at the bid ask
relationship however there are different
types of footprint charts you could look
at you could look at the Delta which is
the horizontal Delta at Price meaning
you know at 105.41 you'd see five trade
on the bid 22 trading on the offer so
that would give you 17 more Lots traded
on the offer so you'd have a positive
Delta of 17 okay because it was traded
on the offer means you had that
aggressive buying meaning it was
positive Delta whereas here at the next
price 105 40 and a half is 31 traded on
the bid 28 traded on the offer means
that
you'd have negative Delta of three at
this price now you also have the volume
footprint which is the total volume
at Price Right so obviously this would
be 220 35 so you also have a diagonal
Delta okay which would be comparing the
delta in the two-way auction okay so
um you know there are different uses for
these the ones that I tend to focus on
the most is the bid ask as well as the
Delta like the horizontal Delta but
let's just go sort of go through them
and show you what they look like right
so this is our again this is our normal
bid ask footprint which majority of
Traders use however you know most order
flow software this is my order flows
Trader 6 software
um other softwares you know they should
have it in some form
um if they don't you know you really
want to go take a look at other other
platforms so again you know bid ask
Delta volume diagonal Delta okay so for
example the volume how does it look
right it's just going to show you the
total volume traded at that particular
particular price it's just going to put
it on one side of the chart you can't
put it on both sides you wouldn't want
to but you can see here right this is
the total volume traded at price now
there are ways to use this
um you know you're going to look for
concentrations of heavy volume at
certain areas in a bar
but again you know maybe that'll be a
different video because that can be a
quite in-depth topic let's take a look
at some of the other Footprints how they
look so you get an idea
so let's go in here at the settings it's
under ladder contents where we hear
volume diagonal Delta again this is the
delta in the two-way auction
foreign
looks
all right you'll you'll see like even
though the bar goes down another price
there's generally the reason why the bar
is still showing that Wick even though
there's no Delta there is because it was
um zero Delta
um but the other chart I like to look at
in addition to
the bid ask what print is the the Delta
footprint right Delta at Price people
say why do you use Delta at price and
not
um the diagonal Delta well it's because
I'm analyzing you know where the trading
was taking place was it taking place on
the bid or the offer
um at that price you know that that's
what I'm interested in I've spent a lot
of time with Delta Footprints over the
years you know it's it's a secondary
chart that I look at after the bid ask
footprint
so you can see here right you get a nice
clean picture of
in my opinion it gives you a better idea
of where absorption is is appearing than
the diagonal Delta chart
and this is Euro currency but
you know on thinner markets that don't
trade a lot of volume you know relative
to say the e-minis
it's kind of nuanced right you have to
spend a lot of time understanding what
heavy heavier
Delta is going to look like in a bar
okay to get a good idea you know there's
certain things that I like to see you
know when a market is moving up or
moving down in the Delta footprint right
I like to see obviously all the bids
getting hit on a red candle right that's
just telling me a strong aggressive
selling in the bar obviously
um just as you know if a bar is rising
up I like to see you know bids also
coming in near the top of These Bars
tell me the market is getting bid up I
don't want to just see uh aggressive
buying yeah I mean that's what you
expect to see but when I sort of see
things that aren't really visible to the
naked eye like here right this Market
had this nice little pop-up right yeah
you expect to see positive Deltas in
these bars but when I see you know a
market sort of come in make a little bit
of a low here swing low and then start
to trade higher then I'm seeing some
nice bids coming in to absorb whatever
aggressive selling is taking place
then you know that gives me an idea that
hey you know what someone is bidding up
this Market as opposed to just
aggressive buyers coming in and taking
the market higher right because for
Market to go higher yes you do need
those aggressive uh buyers to come in
but what you also need is some nice
passive buyers right people bidding the
market not just people lifting the offer
but people supporting the market with
their bids to take it higher
now let's uh just change gears really
quick here let's go to an e-mini chart
today
and take a look at the Delta footprint
right Delta footprint again you know
gives you an insight into the market
that you probably wouldn't have just you
know looking at a normal bid ask
footprint unless you're really
I say I'll say really experience but
more experience with looking at the
um volume footprint or the around I want
to say volume footprint but the bid ask
footprint and really what it's going to
give you sort of insights into like I
said where absorption
is taking place in the market so let's
just go back uh you know sort of earlier
today you know around the cash open to
sort of take you through it right so
Cash open here right and you know we
popped up we started trading down down
and we get this nice green bar nice
green bar up in the market sort of
reverse and started going higher well
what's in this bar that can tell me that
hey you know what
there is some support coming into this
market right well the market starts
selling off right here in this bar right
after the cash open then it hits this
pocket in here with some nice bids
resting in the market right everyone
talks about oh you got to use a book map
so you can see where the resting
liquidity is well I could see that in a
footprint right because I know what to
look for and that's why I do these
videos to sort of teach you what you
look for I know some people will say in
the comments well this doesn't matter
because it's not showing anything in
live trades well the whole point of
learning right you go to medical school
and you learn how to operate right and
that's what this is doing it's like
teaching you what to look for right so
if you're looking at a Delta footprint
chart you see the market sort of shoot
down right this is a nice bar down you
know 39.55 and a quarter down to 47 and
a quarter you know a nice 7.8 Point move
down in a minute then it runs into this
area where there's some passive buyers
to absorb that selling right then you
see the aggressive buyers come in right
and you're seeing the buying imbalances
on the way back up right even this bar
here sort of seeing the same thing right
we're running into some support in here
some support in here and the market
keeps going up now workout really
interesting a little bit later
um here
this area you know around nine
um you know 9 15 to sort of this 9 30
before it started it had this little pop
up here
was this area in here you can see look
at this you can sort of start to see the
every time it was sort of come down a
little bit but really the interesting
part was when you get down to this 57
area and you just draw a line here right
well obviously this is 54 and a half but
every time These Bars push down into
this area you can see the negative Delta
the negative Delta the negative Delta
the negative it's just like there was
some decent bids in here
right you could just see it every time
it would come in
these bids would absorb that selling
Market would trade back up come back in
absorb that selling Market trade back up
now here this was interesting because
you had a big offer up in here on the
Delta was 790 so there was some
resistance in here
so okay I know I've got resistance
coming in here at 62. so let me just
draw a line here okay
and I know I have support down here
every time we come in here we're just
sort of hanging around and then rallies
up so I know I've got this area
okay now keep this in mind
this is the area you're looking to buy
in you know 57 down to 54 and a half you
know call it 56.
your stops just below this area here at
54. if you're buying it in here your
first Target you're buying it at 56 up
to 62 that's six points but I know that
I have this resistance here if I can get
past this
it can shoot up even further so imagine
you know you're looking to buy around
the 56 area first Target 62.
second target
and I'll call it 66 up in here there's
66 or you know I don't want to say oh
you'd call it up here at 70 see it came
up there no you know
this is your first Target
another Target you know is is 10 points
from your entry and you know you're
buying it at 56 a stop at 54. you're
risking two points okay
you get plenty of opportunity in here
right because you know you've hit this
resistance area you're coming back in
support
you just buy it in here in this area not
just anywhere you buy it in this area
with a Target up here because you know
that if we can get past this
resistance it can keep going
it doesn't mean it's going to keep going
the rest of the day up but at least it
can get past clear out that resistance
it should go higher so again you're
risking two points for six points
and 10 points okay and you can see once
it got past that resistance area you can
see the aggressive buying coming in here
with these bind imbalances 46 156 then
it's going up in here 69 162 you know
bear in mind
these imbalances these are actually
Delta imbalances Okay so
there's still a buying imbalance but you
also have that buying and balance still
showing up in the Delta and it gets past
it right that's what you like to see as
you're going through resistance right
you want to see that aggressive buying
and as you get past to still see
aggressive buying it's one thing to have
aggressive buying going into resistance
yes that's nice but if you get past that
resistance and you still see aggressive
buying it's telling you there's more to
this move because you know a lot of
times
you know people thinking oh we're going
up we're going up they get excited fomo
um
you know the aggressive buyers are are
active but once you get past that
resistance and you still see aggressive
buying that's a sign that there's still
more to this move to be had and it pops
right up
um past 66 all the way up to 68 you know
up to 70. okay so you know that's a way
that you can use a Delta footprint to
sort of you know find these areas of
support and resistance by looking at the
Delta volume that's going through and
when I see a lot of bars sort of forming
a base like this and I just see that
absorption coming in every time it sort
of pokes down into this area
and it's just met with strong passive
buying in the sense that there's resting
liquidity in the market and the market
sort of popped back up and if I can
identify an initial Target
then you know I'm set right I don't know
what the trade is going to be
so
I hope you guys got something out of
this video you know be sure to like And
subscribe the channel you know this what
keeps me uh wanting to make more and
more videos is is to teach you guys what
to look for in the market
so thanks everyone I'll see you guys on
the next video